harry vie à une compagne depuis 2 3 ans
et jusqu'à 14h 15h s'appelle sarah
l'insee une fille formidable il vit avec
elle et c'est on avait dit que c'était
elle qui avait porté plainte alors comme
quoi il faut se méfier des médias n'a
appris qu'à 18 heures très tardives ne
sait pas elle donc c'est très important
c'est donc tout le monde l'a appris en
plus c'est l'halloween l'appui tout le
monde derrière elle avec une journée
vraiment compliqué alors que ça n'est
pas elle voilà donc c'est pas elle c'est
pas ça râle in qui s'accompagne depuis
deux trois ans voilà alors il aurait
rencontré quelqu'un samedi soir et c'est
cette jeune fille qu'il a rencontré
samedi soir qu'il ne connaissait pas
avant qui a porté plainte dimanche voilà
pour viol et très précisément voilà là
ça recommence c'est la même histoire
c'est parole contre parole c'est
dramatique comme histoire il faut quand
même dire que ary abittan a déjà été
marié évidemment pas fini mon fils il a
trois filles qui ne veut plus parce que
je sais moi je veux 50 pas mal et je
sais que les jeunes femmes parfois
qu'ils rencontrent elles veulent ou se
marier ou avoir des enfants avec lui lui
il n'en veut plus il dit très clairement
il est très clair avec sa compagne sarah
line comme il les doit être clair avec
les jeunes filles qui rend compte il ne
veux pas d'histoires comme ça pas
d'enfants pas de mariage rien il est
très clair et certaines ne prennent très
mal alors on souligne que ça peut être
une histoire de vengeance une histoire
de on sait pas cela c'est parole contre
parole à tout faire c'est ça c'est tout
ce qu'on peut dire jusqu'à présent si
vous voulez pour être honnête c'est tout
ce qu'on peut dire qu'à présent voilà la
garde à vue a été prolongée mais c'est
pas parce qu'une garde à vue est
prolongée que ça veut dire que il sera a
mis en examen il n'y a absolument aucun
lien c'est parce que les enquêteurs
veulent établir tous les faits là où je
réponds quand même à bernard c'est que
vous avez l'air quand même de
sous-entendre que ce serait une
vengeance ou parce qu'on veut pas se
marier avec lui attention bernard juste
savoir si la dictée une fille qu'il
avait connu sa nuit
je dis simplement que l' on ne sait pas
s'il ya une victime réelle d'un possible
viol il faut être très prudent pour ça
que ça n'a rien à voir le lieu est mise
en examen exactement de suivre
discernement il ya une enquête qui est
fait pour établir tous les faits berlin
effectivement c'est la pj qui vous avez
vous a vu ses proches et je oui c'est ça
tout le monde est sous le choc alors là
franchement c'est la grosse surprise
parce qu'on le connaît très bien et
c'est toujours pareil on qu'un amour
emmené a beau connaître les gens on sait
pas tout non plus dans leur intimité moi
je peux vous dire qu'évidemment je n'y
crois pas à cette histoire moi je le
défends parce que donner son avis je
sais juste mon avis je sais comment il
est et quel rapport il a avec les femmes
il est toujours extrêmement correct
c'est un mec archi honnête vraiment donc
je ne crois pas à cette histoire voilà
une rencontre d'un soir violent le
lendemain je sais pas c'est je n'y crois
pas voilà je ne crois pas je crois que
j'ai découpé ont rencontré en soirée il
a toujours été adorables bestioles il a
toujours été gentil adore ce défi là il
est correct donc ouais il est très
correct ses membres est à prendre oui
mais je veux juste que ce qu'on fait là
on atteint donc de faire le procès un
bon procès n'en est classé à 6,6 des
nôtres on est bas n'ont jamais on en est
on dit on est en crise c'est pas ça on
est en direct et moi j'en sais rien
effectivement de toute façon dans tous
les cas ce sera horrible mais tu dis
quand même par principe et c'est un gars
bien je le connais donc je pense qu'il
est innocent tibet c'est tout un honneur
mais ce qu'ont expliqué il ya des deux
minutes du coup de tombes est ce que tu
fais là exactement la même chose donc
c'est pourquoi le procès qu'on fait le
procès qu'on fait c'est le procès de la
gérer pourquoi des médias parce
qu'effectivement voici qui sort l'info
déjà voici sur une mauvaise info m'a dit
que c'est sa femme d'autres déjà c'est
une info mais oui certains faux mais
donc déjà une info qui n'est pas une qui
n'est pas voilà qui n'ont pas
entièrement ils sortent une mauvaise
info qu à 18h change donc là encore une
fois il faudrait que normalement rien
rien rien ne sorte au moins jusqu'à la
fin de la garde à vue c'est de ça qu'il
faudrait au moins tu vois que je dire
non est entrain de débats de quelque
chose on en dire ou koné need to know
aboutissait pas et en plus sur une info
qui change toutes les quatre heures
c'est hallucinant et mathieu je suis
jamais vous vivez dans un drôle de monde
les journalistes de faits divers de
voici du parisien d'ailleurs ibos 24
heures sur 24 il appelle is appel pour
dans les commissariats ou et chez les
personnes que l'autorité pour avoir les
mains courons tous cas été déposé ary
abittan garde à vue n'importe quel média
le sort aujourd'hui d'ailleurs tous les
meilleurs qu'avant j où il sortait des
infos les médias sortent et des infos
aujourd'hui les médias sorte d'effet dès
qu'elles ont un faible le sorte n'y a
rien qui ait vérifié la preuve quatre
heures après se trompe de nom c'est
imbert encore non l'inversé il n'y avait
pas
juste violent pour être précis c'est une
pénétration sexuelle soit avec violence
soit avec contrainte soit avec menace
soit avec surprise alors c'est pour ça
que tu dis parole contre parole l'ont
signé un viol il ya autre chose qu'une
parole guillaume ouvrages non mais en
fait j'y lis à des tribunaux pour juger
les affaires et tout ce que tu veux
c'est une double sanction ça tu fais une
sanction judiciaire qui n'a même pas eu
lieu parce que là la femme n'a pas été
jugée et tu veux une sanction médiatique
est immédiate encore une fois ce qui me
gêne c'est que dans les autres affaires
pour les personnes qui ne sont pas
médiatisés tout le monde n'a pas être au
courant la sanction elle est judiciaire
elle n'a pas être médiatique la ya des
millions de personnes qui sont au
courant qu'il est accusé de viol est ce
que c'est normal je ne pense pas parce
que les gens malheureusement comme le
disait matthew taylor sont des
raccourcis dans leurs têtes très vite
lisa peine les articles vous croyez gens
utilisent vraiment les articles
intégralement l'accusé de viol présumé
innocent et c'est énorme voire violent
terminée voilà malheureusement et c'est
terrible aujourd'hui dans la société on
ne lit plus rien on s'intéresse plus à
rien et on lit des tweets on juge comme
ça à travers les réseaux sociaux je
trouve que c'est pas bien de sortir
s'appelle et la sortie des mais aussi
des faux bernard juste là pour
les films qui vont sortir avec lui etc
si cette affaire même s'ils s'avèrent
vrai bien sûr ccc catastrophique si
elles s'avèrent fausses pour lui c'est
catastrophique aussi comment ça va se
passer mais déjà il devait commencer un
spectacle sur scène post qui s'appelle
pour de vrai à partir du 18 décembre et
il a son film qu'est ce qu'on a encore
fait au bon dieu le numéro 3 qui sort
lui le 2 février qui repoussait c'est
catastrophique
campus vous accusez comme ça parce que
ça reste ça laisse toujours des traces
et ça s'est tracés sont indélébiles ya
rien à faire ça c'est terrible moi je le
on était tous catastrophés franchement
vraiment on est on est très choqués de
ce qui est arrivé cette violence là
parce que voyez comme quoi on peut pas
faire confiance on a dit que c'était sa
compagne alors tout le monde est tombé
sur elle et les copains et 7 monde l'a
appelé j'irai en fait c'est il se trouve
qu'à 18 heures c'est pas sa compagne et
je suis très étonné aussi que la police
donne autant de renseignements ou de
détail c'est çà çà çà çà c'est très
choquée quand même que la police sur
parce que c'est la police qui donne des
détails et qui vivent et qui les
rémunère à toute la police bien ça tout
mais c'est
un travail de journaliste est un métier
qui s'appelle fait diversier là c'est
une catégorie de journalistes qui
s'occupe ce qu'on dise que des faits
divers donc de là une police justice et
donc leur boulot h 24 c'est de se
reconnaître les policiers les
commissaires les op j etc etc et
d'essayer de récolter un maximum
d'informations
donc normalement c'est
évidemment au lycée ce serait de
l'instruction aïda mais leur boulot à
eux dieuze justement avoir ces
informations vous avez eu qui dans
beaucoup de l'épreuve a vraiment les
très proches s'y attendait pas du tout
c'est sa meilleure amie j'ai eu des
copains âgé de 20 ans avant toi on se
voit beaucoup au moins c'était samedi
soir apparemment on ne serait venu
chercher dimanche matin
c'est ça donc elle à la plainte a été
déposée dimanche matin déjà le lendemain
de sa rencontre du samedi soir d'accord
que voilà évidemment tout le monde est
très choqué personne n'y croit mais là
ça recommence c'est parole contre parole
celle entre eux moi je n'y crois pas
personnellement je ne juge pas je peux
rien dire évidemment mais je le redis je
suis choqué que ce soit aussi vite sorti
dans la presse avec n'importe quoi quand
il ya il a pu prévenir qu'elle tombe pas
du tout une part non justement il y
avait un problème d'avocats figueiredo
c'est très curieux ça oui je ne savais
pas quel avocat appelés donc c'est très
curieux je sais qu'il a droit qu'à un
seul coup de fil me semble non c'est pas
ça
il a le droit de demander la désignation
d'un avocat l'avocat n'est n'est pas
joignable où est empêché pour demander
la désignation d'un autre avocat et
ainsi de suite jusqu'à même prendre un
avocat commis d'office parce que jusqu'à
cet après midi je peux vous dire qu'il y
avait un souci d'avocats on ne trouvait
pas l'avocat nécessaires pour établir la
vérité le temps que d'autant que vrai ou
faux encore une fois mais quand vous
êtes connu je vous laisse imaginer la
violence pour les enfants bien sûr ça
doit elle a trois filles bien c'est
quelque chose c'est abominable passe
elle aussi il faut se remettre elle
n'assure que sur les placements sûrs
mais encore une fois ça quand vous
n'êtes pas connu s'il aimait de phase
iib les médias voilà ne relaie pas ce
genre d'information quand vous n'êtes
pas connu il ya ces cibles que ce soit
par
lycée violent tous les enfants tous les
jours non v6 tout le temps tout le temps
tout le temps qu'il faut nourrir
constamment je suis désolé mais il est
impossible que ça casse autre pierre
juste sa famille ses proches l'ont
appris par la presse aussi ah bah oui
tout le monde la wii par les eaux qui
n'ont heureusement qui la servent en
rapport avec sa première femme c'était
épouvantable il a de très bons rapports
avec sa première femme qui s'est
d'ailleurs remarier les trois filles
c'est épouvantable en plus ils
n'arrêtent pas de 2,2 fin à ses filles
c'est le plus important pour lui au
monde c'est sûr que c'est un séducteur
c'est sûr que quand on veut passer une
soirée avec lui séduit tout le monde
c'est un mec extrêmement marrant et
c'est bien qu'ils n'avaient plus de
nouvelles de lui il sourit à noël a
disparu
un journal nouvelles on a juste juste
après midi qu'il avait un problème
d'avocats qui ne trouvaient pas d'avocat
et on m'a même demandé à moi si je
connaissais un avocat capable de
défendre ou de t'occuper de cette
affaire c'est dingue je trouve
incroyable il a droit qu'à un seul coup
de fil c'est ça je crois pas faim par
jour ça fait deux fois que
je
crois qu'il a droit qu il a le droit
non mais c'est vrai que c'est la
terrible ça nous attriste tous
pour la jeune fille si c est ça sert ici
même et bien sur l'appréciation autant
que pour lui si parce que c'est vrai que
voilà de quoi qu'il arrive cette affaire
nous attriste énormément on espère qu'on
va voir des nous assez vite et bat
dernière vous nous direz en tout cas
c'est vrai que pour sa famille pour ses
amis imaginez le choc ça doit être mon
cliquer oui mais c'est nous on parle des
quotas mais il ya les six filles surtout